we're speaking about issues that are
Islamic related and you're using the FW
so I walked off entered into my car and
then this brother comes behind
me so guys if you are somebody who
trains like me when I'm doing boxing
when I'm jogging when I'm doing
bodybuilding this can benefit you it's
from Nature's Blends as you guys
know I get my honey my black seed oil
and many other supplements from them it
has 86 plus minerals including zinc
magnesium selenium f acid 59% fully lab
tested the highest in the market boost
testosterone levels Boost energy levels
and safe for men and women so check out
Nature's Blends in the description box
and enjoy
itam brothers and sisters and dear
friends this topic at hand is something
that I myself have been talking about
for the past 10 years a decade yes many
times I've told brothers who are in the
scene that you guys are oppressing
people you're talking without knowledge
and nobody listen listened not that
anyone special for that matter they
don't listen listen to me but it is what
I was saying was from Islam it was a h
we would tell people stick to your lane
stick to doing da stop talking about
things that you're not qualified about
and that was ignored why because they
thought they know better alhamdulillah
finally finally an honorable brother
somebody who doesn't oppress others and
even if he did at one moment of time has
repented for it somebody who's not not
known to backbite somebody who's not
known to harm people with this Tong or
with his hands but rather he himself was
harmed not by people speaking out
against him and talking ill of him and
backbite him and slandering him yes and
backstabbing him when he most needed it
like many people we know who do that
they also harmed him with their with
their hands and may Allah break their
hands these are the individuals and this
not only happened to Abu may Allah bless
and preserve him for the service that he
gives to the umah that he assumes the
best in the Believers he doesn't look
for the slip up of the datat like other
backstabbers do and we know who we're
talking about yeah like sagid yeah and
many individuals like him who look for
the fault who look for the mistake of
those who are on the front line trying
to defend the cam of Allah this not only
happened to Abu this also happened to
ABD Hassan I can remember when I was
studying science of Hadith with ABD
Hassan in his house and I
benefited many with many other topics uh
um and I studied many other topics with
him andam benefited greatly till this
day I use that knowledge in my daah may
Allah bless and preserve him there's
certain things obviously I don't agree
with ABD Hassan but it's not to the
level where I would war against him or
call him an innovator all that kind of
nonsense for that
matter was attacked physically yes
physically here is a clip from his own
mouth I spent right myid in UCL hospital
I give him salams no return of the
salams the first thing he says to me is
right why do you sit with innovators
till he started using the FW
we're speaking about issues that are
Islamic related and you're using the FW
so I walked off entered into my car and
then this brother comes behind me and
punches my mouth through the window what
you guys saw there brothers and sisters
is AB telling you guys how he got
attacked and punched in the face this
was not just him these individuals have
not just oppressed physically him it
also happened in Speakers Corner when
brother Ahmed was attacked by Jedi yes
and the same brother Ahmed when Muhammad
hijab and the brothers came to help him
and defend him these individuals
attacked them yes and not only that
Ahmed himself was also punched in the
face by a brother who comes to speak his
K who is associated with them his very
friend punched Ahmed in the face and he
knows who he is he was punched in the
face not only that brother isma who
passed away may Allah have mercy on him
due to cancer he was also punched
slapped in the Masid of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him ABD and
Hassan was grabbed by the throat I can
remember him telling us this story and
if I'm not mistaken brother Imran was
there as well with him that he was
grabbed by the neck by this oppressive
thugs cult member thugs that's what they
are we hate their actions for the sake
of Allah here is a video of Abu a 5our
video which I recommend everyone to
watch especially those who understand
what's going on for some people it can
go over their head don't worry about it
if you know what's you know they say in
the road if you know wagan watch if you
don't ignore it brothers and sisters
this zul and oppression has been done so
many times by these thugs yes and I
would love for them to come and try it
yes on individuals like myself try to
put your hand on me let's see what
happens to you yeah so these guys who
continuously oppress the Muslims finally
alhamdulillah Abu has come and done a
five and a half hour video showing their
double standards and their hypocrisy by
their Scholars our Scholars that we take
from them as well
mean b Alani and the rest
even which we respect we do not agree
with everything that's been said but the
point at hand is what you can see in
this video he breaks down and exposes
them to such a level that we' have got
individuals like FIS yes Farris this
person who used to be a bodybuilder
became a she overnight telling us we
should be careful who comes in da but
for some odd reason somebody who's a
bodybuilder who becomes a she or a Muti
is fine he can just come and say
whatever he likes and bear in mind who
is Faris Farris is someone who recently
attacked Aki Aman and Farris is the same
one who blames Palestinians for what
they are going through pales betrayal
Saudi and there's no betrayal we're
supporting Palestinians all the way
betrayal having Palestinians in
sou when have you critici Israel yes and
I am still waiting for him to talk out
against Israel oh yeah you can't oh yeah
you can't cuz it will affect you it
might affect you we understand we
understand don't worry yes you can't
talk out against them brothers and
sisters these people are cancer to the
um have they have attacked many duat if
you go to them and I'm going to end on
this if you go to them and said can we
listen to M NOP can we listen to Al no
no mu no Ali no Muhammed hijab no um can
we take from Islam Q&A no they will give
you a list of a group of people like
hundreds of du look at the arrogance
that you cannot watch all of these
people and who should you watch a few
selected two three of them alhamdulillah
Allah subhana sent AB may Allah bless
him and preserve him and W he if there
is anybody that I would say who
represents the salaf the early righteous
pred predecessors who has good and who
have I've never seen attack back by
backstab D and have good assumptions and
if he has a he would come and contact us
directly and he's done myself many times
Ali this this came out like just wanted
to clarify with you not somebody who
looks for the fault how can I catch him
where you can see a disease in the heart
may Allah bless and preserve and I will
say out right I know there are many
things that might not agree with some of
the stuff that I do alhamdulillah but
you can see the true knowledge that he
has you can see it and anyone who has an
atam weight of knowledge can see that if
there was anybody that you can say who
follows the Sal I would say is Abu
alhamdulillah and may Allah Preserve his
great service to the um increase him you
know why when we see people who come and
Aid the religion we get happy people
like where I might have he might have
many differences with myself but W his
da is the da of the H his da the way it
is done not by the tongue but the way he
conducts himself the way his mannerism
is this is how the Sal was so I would
ask you guys brothers and sisters watch
this 5 and a half hour video because it
is a great eye opener to many youngsters
being sucked into this cult and ruining
their self and I'll end on this and I've
said this a couple of times forgive me
there was a specific individual a couple
of them who used to backbite me a lot
who came and apologized there is one
specific brother who used to be with
them he came recently he fell off the
dean and this is what it does to you it
destroys your heart it makes you more
occupied with what others are doing and
this person's innovator that person
innovator and this person misguided and
this person is this and this person did
da the wrong way you know he should have
done it like that from individuals who
are Medina students who are sitting in
their bedrooms little bedrooms Medina
students doing reaction videos can you
imagine going to Medina for 8 years and
you sit down and all you do is criticize
other du in way eight years eight years
and you're sitting down all you doing is
criticizing others Allah subh exposes
watch the video in in brother and
sisters that's all I want to say and
those who have raised their hands to
individuals like ABD Hassan yes and
brother is and even those who even
whoever it may be may Allah subhana wa
ta'ala break bre their backs like they
would use on others may Allah break your
backs or guide you and forgive you for
the that you've done on the Muslims who
are defending the calam of Allah subana
tal against his enemies while you throw
arrows behind their back watch this
video
inah